welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and stranger things season four has
a new sneak peek that confirms a release
in 2022
with 10 whole seconds of new trailer
footage from the upcoming season and
plenty of clock imagery to decode
i'm gonna break this down frame by frame
for all the clues
including what could be the new dnd
based monster that connects everything
and it's not the monster you think okay
we actually open with the shot we saw
back in the 11 are you listening teaser
from may
11 you're listening which did make it
seem like eleven could be back in the
hawkins lab or maybe a flashback tour
times with dr
brenner before the events of season one
but then this montage of big moments
from the first three seasons until we
arrive at the new footage
okay so let's start with this new shot
of a grandfather clock striking 12 and
what appears to be a rundown attic now
this could be the same house as one that
steve dustin robin max nancy and lucas
explore in the other shot and that is
believed to be the claremont house of
rome georgia which the show's production
made to look all boarded up and
abandoned to be
the creel house of hawkins now robert
englund the horror legend who played
freddy krueger in the nightmare on elm
street series has been confirmed in the
cast this season as a guy named victor
creel
a disturbed man who was imprisoned in a
psychiatric hospital for a gruesome
death in the 1950s but i think he'll be
more of a boo
radley figure associated with this small
town urban legend of killing a family
member in this house
but in reality the death was a result of
a supernatural force and he received the
blame maybe you could even look at him
as what will byers would have become
had he stayed in hawkins and grown up as
a character that people were kind of
afraid of which brings us back to this
clock now remember a clock was in the
tree and upside down in the very first
season four announcement in september
with the chimes of a grandfather clock
precisely at 12.
[Music]
and then a year later in october 2020 an
official set photo showed the clock
again with the message
meanwhile in the upside down and then in
the 11 can you hear me spot we got
another close-up of a clock on the wall
now when it comes to clock imagery the
mind goes to time travel maybe even the
cold war doomsday clock
but that clock in the upside down and
the announcement clip didn't look like a
grandfather clock that would have a
pendulum making me think that the chimes
we heard
actually came from this one in the attic
so
could these two clocks be linked and
that precisely at the strike of 12
twice a day a gateway is open between
them from
our reality to the upside down through
these clocks almost like the vanishing
cabinets of harry potter and through
this gateway back in the 50s arrived the
threat perhaps even the demogorgon who
actually butchered the victim that
victor creel was accused of killing now
all we know is that the season will
release sometime in 2022 but i also
wonder if that stroke of
12 could also be a clue that this series
might go live at midnight on
new year's 2022 because think about it
every season is centered around a
holiday season one on thanksgiving
christmas season two halloween season
three fourth of july and i think new
year's would be a pretty good target for
season four
and maybe why they're playing coy just
saying 2022.
another new shot shows 11 being
restrained by government agents
pulled toward the back of a van she has
a new haircut with bangs actually
similar to joyce beyer's hair
remember season 3 ended with 11 leaving
hawkins with the buyers
headed apparently to california and it's
thought that this season might open with
mike visiting them which could be why we
don't see finn wolfhard
with the others in these other shots now
there is a third agent behind them and
the one on the right is actor sherman
augustus playing lieutenant colonel
sullivan who's described as a
no-nonsense man who believes he knows
how to stop the evil and hawkins
just when eleven thought she was out
they pull her back in now matthew modine
is confirmed to return as dr brenner
from season one
so maybe these are brenner's men forcing
eleven to return to hawkins to be part
of their old experimental program
because she's the ultimate weapon that
they need
to face the supernatural threat but
notice how she looks betrayed here
could it be that will sold her out maybe
feeling resentful for his ongoing
psychological scarring and his residual
link to the mind player that you can
take the freaks out of hawkins but you
can't take the hawkins out of the freaks
and will might think that the only way
to leave this curse behind is to force
11 to go back there by the way we here
at new rockstars obviously we're big
nerds who are always crunching the
numbers thinking about things like the
youtube algorithm how people search for
our content just because we're really
proud of what we make we want it to
reach as wide of an audience as possible
and one way that we've been helping
teach ourselves more about things like
that are with services like brilliant
thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video brilliant is an educational
service that really replaces the typical
lecture videos with more hands-on
interactive lessons just a better and
more fun way to learn brilliant has a
course on algorithm design that lets you
learn through these interactive
exercises where you like shift around
blocks of code and it gives you
immediate feedback on your results
brilliant is here to inspire people to
actively play with the ideas of math and
science
and the cool thing about brilliant is
that they're a great complement to
passively watching educational videos
if you want to learn more with math or
physics computer science the best way to
actually learn that
is to actively grapple with puzzles and
problem solving brilliant offers
masterfully designed courses that help
you conquer all sorts of technical
subjects
once i'm done with this algorithm course
i'm eyeballing the search engine and
cryptocurrency courses and honestly i
could stand up to brush up on some math
as well young people watching this you
have no idea how much you actually too
need math in your life and it's not just
the basics brilliant has courses in
applied science number theory quantum
computing all kinds of other stem topics
to support this channel and learn more
about brilliant go to brilliant.org
new rockstars and sign up for free the
first 200 people that go to that link
will get 20
off the annual premium subscription then
again we see the group in the creel
house
nancy steve robin max dustin and lucas
notice how dustin's hat reads thinking
cap and lucas has a flat top looking
good
next hopper his hair is trimmed as it
was from that from russia with love spot
he wears his winter coat
suggesting he could be on the move out
of that siberian prison camp he's got a
flame thrower
looking a lot like mccready and john
carpenter's the thing but look at that
door
that is the same door from the prison
hallway in the season three finale
post-credits scene
when the russian guards referenced an
american in one of the cells so hopper
now might be going cell by cell
to seek out the demogorgon in this
facility and put it down
or maybe put down anyone that the
demogorgon might have infected
then there's a shot of hawkins high
school cheerleaders at a pep rally and
front and center is grace van dien
playing chrissy a new character
described as most popular girl in school
but one who has a secret reports also
say that she's dating a guy who is
described as steve harrington without
the heart i don't know maybe her deep
dark secret could be that she has a
thing for robin
then there's this overturned car on fire
as
will it looks like approaches it maybe
will cause this
wreck a manifestation of his ongoing
link with the mind player
whereas 11 was the carry of the earlier
seasons and now will has these powers he
doesn't feel comfortable with i don't
know i'm just getting some wilter
soldier vibes here
then a shot of steve underwater with a
flashlight looks like he's investigating
a sunken car
this could be in connection with their
investigation of the creel murder like
if victor creole was a norman bates
figure
maybe there was something where he tried
to sink a car in a bog i also fully
expect there to be a jaws jump scare
here like with the dead face popping out
the window at steve like the one that
did to richard dreyfuss in that scene
then this dnd
game with three dice rolling they roll
past this green token
this looks like a vechna figure now
vecta is a character in the game who is
a powerful wizard who became a lich
which is an undead spellcaster
now the recurring thing on this show is
that the kids will use things from d and
d to explain the supernatural phenomena
we had the demogorgon we had the mind
player and now
vecna could be the same thing in fact it
could be what will buyers fears he has
turned into
a wizard turn into a kind of undead lich
then this interesting shot of 11 had
shaven once more
peeking through a window in that same
facility from that 11 ru listening spot
again this could be part of a flashback
to 11's time with dr brenner
or she's back in this lab working with a
new class of kids maybe benner's forces
are
trying to force her to lead a team of
young psychic warriors to
battle the threats from beyond and we
end with some more e.t
goonies bike action you see max dustin
lucas and lucas's sister erica
who i really think needs to call out
lucas for riding a bike when this guy
looks old enough to be driving his kids
to college his kids grow up so fast by
the way you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you